the state religion is pretty broad you
know there was a there was this this
story that came up out of Canada
so it's America's hat it's not in
America but it's similar ethos and I
wouldn't it all be surprised if we saw
the same story in America they in Canada
they painted a crosswalk in rainbow
colors not to remind man that God will
never again destroy the earth in a flood
but to to support sexual liberation and
gay rights but now it's so much so much
more than just homosexuality they're
very upset up in Canada the cops are
investigating a major serious crime
because they found tire marks in the
crosswalk pride crosswalk defaced
outside West Vancouver police station
they're looking for a black Ford Mustang
with red racing stripes along the top
and sides because there were tire marks
in a crosswalk have you ever seen tire
marks in a crosswalk probably you have
because you know what drives over
crosswalks cars you know of course have
tires you know what happens when you hit
the brakes you turn works but this is
any offense to part of the state
religion which is the rainbow not the
old rainbow the new rainbow is
considered a hate crime the worst
possible thing imaginable we saw
yesterday the people are being charged
in America with civil rights violations
with hate crimes for painting over a
black lives matter
Marxist slogan in the streets of a city
that sort of thing that's not gonna have
to go up to the Supreme Court these
people are gonna get the hammer laid
down on them whether it's in America or
in Canada and the Little Sisters of the
Poor are gonna have to wait and wait and
fight and fight for years and years in
court
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description